TK I got to tell you uh I went and saw
you at the ice house and it's the first
time I saw your stand up live in person
yes oh my God it was just just amazing
thank you so much I appreciate you my
man it was good to see you they laughing
too I was dying and and and I finally
saw your significant other and I see you
married beautiful young lady and then
you know it's funny cuz if you take your
lady or your significant other to a TK
show right you're going to laugh and
your girl might look at you like mm
that's so true that's so true you're so
right it's so right yeah but I I I'm I'm
glad that you came out it was really
good look I really appreciate that um
it's crazy too man cuz I feel like uh
more than ever comedy everyone's talking
about comedy isn't that a great thing
shout out to to Cat Williams let show
some love shout out to cat for bringing
um comedy to the Forefront of
entertainment and if you've been around
a long time you know you only get 10
minutes in this game so you got to um
capitalize off this because next week
could to be something else yep right for
sure next week something he's had a
choke the first couple weeks of first
couple week New Year you know puffy
happy you know Puffy's happy yeah
because that we we not talking about him
no more lot of people are happy yeah
everybody happy Jo y everybody's talking
about something else so it's it's it's a
good moment no for sure when you saw the
interview cuz I don't know if you
watched all of it cuz I I didn't watch
any of it so what I did was I talked to
different people right and I saw
different clips and I was able to segue
and put my own it's a lot it's two and a
half hours yeah two so I did my own
thing on it but when at first I had one
opinion mhm what was that first opin the
other opinion was I felt I didn't like
um Shannon sharp allowing cat to talk
about everybody cuz as a man I felt like
yo we don't do that on this show you're
supposed to stop him as a man that's how
I move but then someone told me not t
those people went on those shows prior
to him coming which is almost why he
wanted to go on exactly and and they
talked about him and that's what it
started so then they got what they
deserve yeah it was kind of like fair
game at that yeah absolutely I'm here to
defend myself and retort everything that
been said on the same platform so when I
saw that I I I I respected that and I I
left it that way how much of uh what cat
was saying would you say is you know
entertainment inflated and how much of
it because I feel like that there was
there was enough truth in there for
people to get to talk in but I feel like
there was also certain stuff like yeah I
would say 99% of it was um inflated
right especially the run in the running
the 40 yeah I think I talked about it
you talking about stage used to run
track right I used to run track like you
know and and and and if people don't
know something well you running track at
sees Sun out here I sure was yeah and I
was on my way to the Olympic trials when
I was out here wow and the thing about
um track and if people don't know it you
believe almost anything and I tell
people Cass said he could run a 44 at 50
years old and I said Dion Sanders who
was one of the fastest people in the
world ran a 4-1 when he was 20 something
years old right and and Cat said he ran
that fast with sweats on as a 50y old
man as a 50y old man it just don't add
up don't add so I put 20,000 on the BET
out there to to race cat now it's not
going to be a fast race but you'll win
I'll win it's not going to be a fast
race if if if people saying 44 is fast
me and Cat literally probably run a 40
yard dash
and
S 7 69
maybe 73 74 that's my prediction and you
I me you're the expert so I don't know
how yeah cuz I'm 63 years old so and 63
you're not running a for something it's
impossible or at 50 or 50 it's
impossible unless sure you saying bat
maybe when you say bolts 50 maybe maybe
maybe maybe right yeah as 50 60 years
old you ain't running that fast um talk
about uh a few of the things you were
saying on stage that I was that that I I
of the things I wanted to talk to you
about something that i' heard I've been
hearing a lot more people who are more
um I guess uh financially literate than
me okay talk about how to leverage life
insurance M good question my man well
the insurance game is really um because
I'm very confused about it but I've
heard it so many times and people who I
know they're like yeah you know you can
get taxfree money like like so see it's
it's a lot of levels of the tax right so
let's take whole life insurance mhm
whole life insurance if you created a
policy you call your whoever your agent
is your say State Farm and you say hey I
want to open up a whole life insurance
policy let's just take 100,000 you put
100,000 in and over course of time that
money will grow so fast that you become
your own bank so let's say now you only
got 100,000 let's say you got 200,000
but you want to take 75,000 have to buy
a car put it to bus you can do that and
they won't tax you on the money
what they do is you'll still pay what
you're paying on that um policy but when
you die it comes out they take it off
the top oh so you're almost like
borrowing from yourself after you die
exactly but it's taxfree
exactly that's whole life insurance and
they and these are things I think they
should teach you in school right yeah
because at any given time if an
emergency happens or you have a business
opportunity present itself and you might
think to yourself well I don't have it
you don't have it it but if you had this
damn so let's say you get a $100,000
insurance policy life insurance policy
and you want to take 5,000 out 10,000
you don't have to pay that back they
they'll take it when you when you die as
long as you keep paying your policy you
got to keep paying the policy you got
people C the policy but you can do that
do people like can you have multiple
multiple life insurance policies yeah
yeah for sure some you like um Derek
Jeter has a policy on everybody in his
family I mean I feel like it I feel like
when you hear that out loud it sounds
bad
why yes but it's it's it's smart and
people are afraid to take out insurance
go especially some men if if your wife
or a daughter say Dad we should take out
insurance some people say no because you
don't want to make the other person Rich
you don't want the other person that's
the mindset of most people but in
actuality people are afraid to create a
legacy you have to have a legacy to and
that's one of the best ways Insurance to
do that if you have but then structure
it too because when you get free money
you're going to run through it yeah I
mean I think that that's that's why most
people they turn 18 they get a credit
card exactly if you leave anybody any
money and they didn't work for it unless
they have true discipline or very very
frugal they running through it yo cuz
they never had that kind of money at one
time yeah cuz I know some people will
set up like a trust to pay out your
family once you're right yeah you
certain amount or you got or you got to
do something like you got to go to
school you got to get a degree and then
you're going to get this exactly y you
have to structure it but I've know
people that got millions and ran through
it in a couple years it's crazy one of
my female friends and
um she inherit 1.2 million less than a
year and a half it was all going you
know how answer was I had a good
time but now what exactly but now what
and I'm glad you brought that up cuz the
world needs to hear this you know and
then you got a thing called term life
insurance and term life insurance like
about 9 years you know but you pay on it
every month you need it's protection you
want to be you want no man should be
walking in the street without some sort
of insurance just in case you die you
don't want to put that burden on your
family you know so you have term life
insurance but the clever thing about
term life insurance is after nine years
they give you every dime back it was
like a savings account and that's called
surrender you they'll send you something
in the mail because you because you
you're alive yeah they they have they
have they send this in the mail say you
could surrender your account and they
send you you could fill out the forms
they send you back all that money every
time can you borrow against the ter no
you can't borrow against that okay but
that's just something that is instead of
you putting does it grow in that it
doesn't grow but your protect but
imagine years nine years you put
something in the in and also that money
isn't it's yours if if you don't die
you're getting it back yes and and and
if you don't want to be insured anymore
right so so let's say six years in
you're like you know what I'm good I
need my money back no no no they can't
won't do it that way they'll tell you
when it's time to they want you to
surrender your account you can't tell
them you can't say I got this money here
it's not a bad idea to do a version of
both yes yes so the insurance thing and
you want to have burial
insurance so is that for when you pass
your there's one thing there's life
insurance and you have burial insurance
burial insurance is strictly for the
funeral right but then you let the
people who you love you could take that
or you could take the money out of the
like life insurance policy and pay for
the burial um my kids is all set up you
know I got my stuff that one I'm not
having a funeral so I'm getting created
boom I don't want even a um a service
you so you've already thought about all
that no fun mostly a lot of people don't
know your grandparents at least people
Grand I know have their whole funeral
and everything set up that so for you
you'd rather be pre-med and then have
your ashes spread or it's either either
cremation or I want my I want my ashes
to become a tree
oh yeah or you put my whole body in the
ground and this this thing I forgot what
my daughter said and I could grow as a
tree and they you you're in a certain
place so I'm going to do something
unique and different but I feel like a
funeral is like a vain thing to think
about having cuz it's like because
you're not there you're not there but
you know who did it the best in my
lifetime who Queen
Elizabeth it was on TV yeah you saw how
hero was did you even look at it a
little some of it yeah listen to me it
was the greatest thing I've ever seen in
my life it was masterful I think that
funerals help families grieve that's
true cuz it brings everyone together and
you know it it helps it kind let me tell
you how I look at it I lost my mother my
dad and all my brothers who I was 40 MH
I've been to so many funerals you you it
drive your head crazy as I've gone
through life you know people invest in a
lot of things right people invest in
gasoline Tesla stock and all that I want
people to invest in their time time is
the most precious commodity that you
have that's taken for granted for sure
and when I pass I'm giving the world a
gift what I'm saying to you don't come
to my funeral this time that you
have continue doing what you're doing
just take a moment to say te to the mfk
right and keep it moving because I don't
it's I'm I'm not saying that I want to
waste your time right I just understand
how powerful time is and that's my gift
to the people I want them to
um really take their time seriously cuz
could you imagine if everybody had a
dollar for all the time that they wasted
it is crazy and the and the amount of
things that we can waste our time on now
is greater than ever yes cuz there's a
terminology most people don't use called
um time wasters we all have met them mhm
people in our life wasting your time
yeah met we always met somebody that was
a time waster right it's crazy someone
who doesn't respect your yes yeah it
happens I got a few of those people mhm
so when I do business on the phone what
I do is for someone someone is talking
to me about doing a show yo before we
hang up the phone you got to send me $2
to
$5,000 that way I know you're serious
you're not getting off the phone with me
and I picked up that call and you going
on about your business you decide you
going to do something else cuz you
wasted my time
and it also makes sure that when people
reach out to me they're prepared they
already know what it is a lot of men lot
of people don't know they're not
prepared when they call you they'll say
oh I'm thinking about no I'm not the
person you think about when you called
me you should have been known what
you're doing we're doing this or we're
not doing yeah yeah don't play with me I
do your homework and then call me right
then do your homework then call me yeah
I'm too busy and I stay booked